the the committee consists of former
coaches former general managers former
players here's the reality if these are
human beings who are connected in any
way to the football industry and clearly
they are they're former coaches former
gm's former players
you're not going to completely avoid
the conflicts of interest you're not
going to avoid the relationships that
may cause you to be anything other than
truly objective you're not going to find
a jury out there that doesn't know any
of the parties that doesn't know any of
the witnesses that doesn't know any of
the lawyers and that's one of the things
that you do when you're picking a jury
at the outset of any trial i've done it
more times and i care to remember you
have to find out if anyone on the jury
knows anyone who's going to be on the
witness stand who's going to be sitting
at council table who knows the judge who
knows anyone do they know each other you
want people in there who can make
decisions
with no regard for what it may do to
relationships that already exist that is
a
a a very underrated element of how this
sausage is going to get made chris and
again i don't know who's on the
committee yet i guarantee you that we
will sooner rather than later
but you cannot detach these human beings
from the relationships that they have
and by taking the competition
competition committee out of play
with an acknowledgement that there's a
conflict of interest
it it invites
the speculation
i wonder if i wonder if they're going to
do this guy a favor or you know this guy
they're going to stick it to him because
this guy doesn't like that guy i mean
that's very real in any business and
it's definitely real in the nfl so i
don't know how i feel about this outside
advisory committee being made up of
people who are just not currently
actively part of the nfl well i know but
you know you are going to feel better if
it's people that are you know nothing
will get accomplished if it's people
that are involved in the nfl right now
then an extreme no no no it will they
advise the commissioner and he makes a
decision and he takes into account the
the bias if this is or or or just you
recuse yourself from the competition
committee and let the others on the
committee handle it that would be better
wouldn't it well yeah but there's always
gonna have crosstalk hang on hang on
okay hang on hang on if it but if it
involves the saints or i know there's
tentacles in there yeah there's gonna be
ten of those well when they're in my
division that team's not so screw that
team i like that team right so that's
why i would just say i'd rather have the
outside part i know what you're saying
but here's the thing here's the thing
yeah
the commissioner is still the one who's
making the decisions and i think it
comes down to the commissioner
to make it clear to the people on the
competition committee this is bigger
than your team this is bigger than you
trying to get to the playoffs this is
about the overall integrity of the game
and we need to come to conclusions that
that focus on the best interest of the
sport and maybe he can send that same
message to this outside committee but
they're going to have similar biases and
prejudices that the people on the
committee will have it just the whole
thing
it just makes me
uneasy it and i want to see how it works
you know troy was kind of asked
yesterday what what will the standards
be will there be factors determined
ahead of time i get the impression this
is going to be
let's just address these circumstances
as they come up and and that is not
conducive to the kind of consistency
that is going to keep people like us
from saying why'd you cancel this game
but not that game why did this team get
a break because they didn't have any
healthy offensive linemen and this team
didn't get a break that's what they need
to avoid you know and that's what i'm
concerned is going to filter into this
process the perception of
inconsistencies no i i'm like i hear
your concerns totally i do think you're
avoiding some of those concerns by using
an outside committee rather than guys
that are involved in the game i just
think that won't look as good either you
know i just think for the fans
transparency everything but you know
again we don't know the committee
but you know listen troy vincent's a
smart guy and he's got a good heart and
i don't you know i don't think they're
trying to find guys who you know are in
this for the wrong reasons or you know
or they want guys that are interested
i'm not saying i know i don't know can
you just i'm not saying i'm not saying
there's a sleeper cell but there were
somebody who's infiltrated this
committee with the goal of taking over
the nfl i'm just saying the same
prejudices and biases that will affect
the competition committee are going to
affect the human beings on this outside
committee because they are still close
close enough to the game to be on this
committee right right but i i still
think you can find the right guys out
there that will have yeah right they're
going to root for their own teams or
with our old teams they're all coaches
but still can like look at things from
the outside in and go wait here's the
big picture of the great you know for
for the greater good of the nfl you know
i think of just guys like hey derek
brooks let's say him hey we know he
loves tampa bay buccaneers derek brooks
is smart loves football loves the nfl he
is not going to be overly biased to like
screw the nfl over just for tampa bay or
like if you took let's say a guy like
mike shanahan who's been out of football
for a while you know he you can't have
fun
okay he's a bad example let's say bill
cower okay i'm sorry i'm just trying to
go to an ex-old coach who's out of the
game and i've you know yeah mike's got
kyle so that's not good let's go bill
cower all right let's just say a guy
like that like bill cower is not gonna
like you know
screw over his reputation in the nfl
just so pittsburgh can win a game or
whatever thing like that so i would
think they could find the right guys to
be a part of this committee that have
the big picture of the nfl in mind and
can cancel out some of those biases and
do what's best for the league you know
so i like the committee idea but i
understand your concerns and your doctor
doom and you're always thinking the
worst thing possible no i'm not talking
no i'm not no i'm not no i'm not chris
no no look somebody's got to be
concerned about the worst case scenario
somebody's got to say you know what this
could go off the rails before it goes
off the rails and i'm i'm more concerned
about the lack of standards i'm more
concerned about the potential lack of
consistency because that is what will
invite some
speculation and or investigation as to
whether or not someone was trying to
help a friend or hurt an enemy right
even though you're not currently
actively with a team and i'd like to
think the members of the competition
committee have the integrity to set
aside their own interests to do what's
right for the league they do that every
year when it's time to come up with
rules right why can't they be expected
to do it when it comes time to figure
out what's right for the league when
making these covet 19 decisions so i i
just i
there's just something about this
process that doesn't sit well with me
and i think the main thing that doesn't
sit well is the lack of any type of
standards or rules going in because that
sets the stage for and here's look let's
be realistic this is something we talked
about last week
is it going to be a lower bar to cancel
a game that is one of the cluster of
games at 1 p.m eastern on sunday than it
is to cancel a primetime game
i i mean i know what are you right
yeah
because the prime time hey the prime
time game goes away we got to rebate the
network for that that hole in their
programming right that night we don't
have other games that can be televised
you know if it's a one o'clock game well
wait markets that we're gonna get that
game get a different game well let me
just say this though like here there's
no fans in a lot of these games this
year what's what you know what why not
matter well
hold on a second honey chris can you
just let me finish one sentence during
this damn segment okay all right here we
go no there's one o'clock games if
there's no fans in a year like this
why can't the nfl oh we've had a coven
19 outbreak at you know seven o'clock on
friday night for our sunday night
football game
why can't the nfl call the teams that
one of the teams that wanted two of the
teams at one o'clock and go we're moving
your game from there's no fans we don't
have to tell them we're moving your game
to one to eight o'clock eastern now
you're on sunday night football
congratulations hang up the phone that's
the year we're in screw off sorry i kind
of like that that's another good one
oh no yeah and and we've we've brought
that up yeah the reality that these
games can be shifted
right pretty easily
we see it we see it or we used to see it
more when
baseball and football teams were in the
same stadium team gets to the world
series sunday game becomes a second
monday night game yeah i remember a
broncos vikings game in 1987 that was an
alternate monday night game because the
twins were hosting a game in the world
series yeah i remember that on sunday
and it got bumped to monday night so you
can have two monday night games you can
have games that get shifted around
depending upon when the outbreak is and
i think that's what that committee is
going to be advising the commissioner
what's right to do here and i think
they're going to do all they can to get
the games in yeah
when the time comes to determine to pull
the plug on a game whatever those
factors and standards are there need to
be applicable in every other situation
or that's when the whole thing falls
apart that's what i'm concerned about
and i hope that there is a strong
commitment to consistency in the
application of those standards
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports